هذا رئيس البرازيلي لولاده سيلفا بملاحقه
من سماهم ممولي تحركات الانقلابيه وكشف ان
اجهزه الامن اعتقالات 2500 شخصا على ذمه
التحقيق في اقتحامات مراكز السلطه في
العاصمه البرازيليه
حكام الولايات البرازيليه ال 27 والرؤساء
البلديات الكبرى في القصر الرئاسي
بالعاصمه البرازيليه وقال ان ذا سيلفا ان
المقتحمين
كانوا يهدفون للدعوه الى انقلاب على الحكم
مشددا على ان الديمقراطيه لن تفلت من ايد
البرازيليين مجددا وكان رئيس البرازيلي
ورئيس المحكمه العليا قد وصفوا الاقتحامات
بالعمل الارهابي في حين امر الادعاء العام
باعتقالي وزير الامن العام
اذا نستمع
برازيليه ونقل المعتصمون بحفلات الشرطه
الفيدراليه وبات لدينا اكثر من 1500 معتقل
لهم تحقيق عادل لمعرفه من كان منهم متعمدا
ومن شارك طلبه
هذه الممارسه
الى الانقلاب على الحكم
كيفيه
لم يكونوا يحتاجون على اداء الحكومه
بالاراضي الانقلاب والانقلاب لن يحدث في
بلدنا يجب ان يتعلم ان الديمقراطيه هي
اكثر النظم تعقيدا وهي التي تعلمنا
التعايش الاحتجاج مقفول ولكن مع الحفاظ
على الديمقراطيه لانها نظام الوحيد الذي
يضمن لنا وصول الفائز بالانتخابات الى
الحكم
الدمار الذي حل الذي قسم رئاسه في العاصمه
البرازيليه بعد استئنافه العمل في مكتبه
بعد اقتحام مؤيد رئيس اليمن
الحضاري معتبران ان ما جرى غير مسبوق في
تاريخ البلاد
وعرضت وسائل الاعلام من برازيليه صورا
لعمليات تفتيش تقوم بها قوات الامن
لاعتصام لانصار الرئيس السابق جير
بورسنارو المقام قرب مقر الجيش في العاصمه
البرازيليه وبينما استدعت السلطات قوه
اضافيه الى العاصمه تواصل قوه الامن
فضعتصام مؤيد فول سونارو وتنقلهم في
حافلات تابعه للحكومه تمهيدا لمقادتهم
وفقا لوسائل الاعلام برازيليه
الاقتحام
ومدبرهارون
في البلاد في اشاره الى قانون العفو الذي
حمى لعقود افرد الجيش المتهمين بارتكاب
انتهاكات وقتل خلال الحكم الديكتاتوريه في
البلاد بين عامي 64 و 85 من القرن الماضي
في غضون ذلك نشر رئيس البرازيلي السابق
جرير بول سينارو صوره له في المستشفى في
مدينه اورلاندو بالولايات المتحده
الامريكيه مذكرا بحادثه تعرضه للطعن في
بلاده خلال حمله الانتخابيه عام 2018 كما
اشار بون سونارو الى خضوعه لخمس عمليات
جراحيه بعد عمليه الطعن والى تجدد
المضاعفات بين الحين والاخر وهو مضطره
الدخول الى المستشفى امس الاثنين